رغم القلق منه بالتاكيد هناك فوائد مهمه
للذكاء الاصطناعي شركه نت اعلنت عن خطتها
للحفاظ على 4000 لغه طبعا مشاهدينا كل هذا
الكم من اللغات المنطوقه اطلقت عليها
واطلقت عليها متى نماذج الكلام الضخمه
المتعدده اللغات وذلك بهدف حفظها من
الانقراض تزعم ان هذه النماذج قادره على
تحويل النص الى كلام والعكس باكثر من
1200 لغه وهي زياده بعشره اضعاف على ما
كان موجودا في وقت سابق
وقد جعلت متانماذجها الجديده
مفتوحه حتى يتمكن الباحثون من الوصول
اليها والمساهمه في تطويرها من اجل
المساعده في الحفاظ على لغات العالم
كل لغات العالم حبيتك والله العالم يا
سلام رومانسي على الصبح بس على فكره موضوع
اللغات وانقراض هذا شيء مهم جدا وخطير جدا
عملت حلقه بودكاست في برنامج كلام منطقي
من فتره من كم شهر ولما عملت البحث انصدمت
من يعني تفاصيل فيما يتعلق باللغات بانه
مثلا
في المحيط الهادي لوحدها فيها 800 و880
لغه تقريبا بينما بكل اوروبا في يعني 200
لغه تقريبا من اللغات الاصليه وغير طبعا
المخاطر اللي بتتهدد لغات كثيره منها في
بعض الاحيان اللغه العربيه
مش بالانقراض ولكن بدايه الاندثار بسبب
العولمه وانتشار اللغات اللغه الانجليزيه
تحديدا هو لربما هي اللغه واللهجه يجب ان
نفرق بينهم انه اللهجه هي منتشره اليوم في
العالم العربي لدينا عده لهجات ولكن لدينا
لغه عربيه واحده اليوم بعض المفردات ربما
كانت حتى في العصر الجاهلي في العصر
الجاهلي والشعر الجاهلي القديم بعض
المفردات ذهبت الشعراء العصر الاسلامي صدر
الاسلام وما بعدها لم يستخدمها فبالتالي
اليوم تتغير اللغه العربيه جميله
كاللغه المرضعه مش لانه انا عملته هذا
الحلقه تعلمت كتير كتير شغلات عن اللغه
اللي مهتم بقدر يتفرج عليها كلام منطقي
اسمها ليلى واللغه وراح نسمعها نتابع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات